[Musik]
mein heutiger gast ist seit jahren eine
der beliebtesten und gleichzeitig
umstrittensten deutschen politikerinnen
bekannt aus zahlreichen talkshows und
trotzdem immer ein bisschen rätselhaft
und unnahbar geblieben
ja und plötzlich haben ihr körper und
seele gesagt es geht nicht mehr
burnout und sarah wagener hat die
konsequenzen gezogen und sich aus der
spitze ihrer fraktion zurückgezogen
herzlich willkommen bei phoenix
persönlich guten tag frau wagenknecht
wie geht es ihnen heute
auch ich muss sagen gut also obwohl
viele und welche rogan schnupfen und
husten also mich hat es noch nicht
erwischt es ist etwas sehr
ungewöhnliches dass ein politiker sagt
es geht nicht mehr sie haben das getan
wie schwer war dass ich habe mit so
einer entscheidung ringt man natürlich
schon lange
ich wollte ja auch fraktionsvorsitzende
werden ich bin ja nicht geprügelt worden
das zu machen aber ich hatte doch aus
vielen erlebnissen das gefühl ich bin da
in einem punkt wo ich nicht weiter
kommen wo ich auch nichts mehr bewegen
und ich will ja etwas bewegen dafür bin
ich in die politik gegangen
und wenn man merkt dass man auf einem
pfad irgendwo sich also noch gegen wände
läuft dann finde ich muss man sich auch
selber eingestehen
das ist jetzt nicht der weg das heißt
nicht dass ich jetzt nur noch
privatperson bin ich bin nach wie vor in
der politik aktiv aber eben auf andere
weise also haben sie selber gesagt sie
sind nach wie vor bundestag aktiv kommen
ja auch nach wie vor in fernsehsendungen
zum beispiel jetzt heute in diesem sinn
was haben sie denn geändert an ihrem
leben
ja ich habe natürlich das was mich viel
kraft gekostet hatte und das was ich
eher als unproduktiv empfunden ab diese
art termine die konnte ich massiv
reduzieren
also es ist ja klar wenn man eine
fraktion für dann vertritt man sie nicht
nur nach außen sondern man muss sehr
viel auch internes management konflikte
interne reibereien das muss man
irgendwie handeln damit muss man sich
beschäftigen man muss sich um die
fraktion um die einzelnen
fraktionsmitglieder kümmern wie in jeder
partei gibt es sehr viel interne
konflikte gerade aktuell wir sehen das
in allen parteien cdu spd in der linken
leider auch und es war so dass doch
diese internen konflikte mich sehr stark
also erstmal das war ein teil budget wo
ich irgendwann gar nicht mehr den kopf
frei hatte um neue ideen zu entwickeln
oder auch wirklich nach außen noch gut
zu wirken wenn ich menschen überzeugen
will
und das muss ich heute nicht mehr wir
wollen nachher noch ausführlich darüber
reden was was zu diesem burnout geführt
hat ob vielleicht der ganze
politikbetrieb unmenschlich ist habe
mich interessiert natürlich auch ihre
ansicht zur aktuellen politik beginnen
wir mal in thüringen nach vier wochen
auszeit ist bodo ramelow jetzt wieder
gewählt worden zum ministerpräsidenten
von thüringen
wie beurteilen sie denn das was sich da
ereignet hatte thueringen.de letzten
wochen eher man fragt sich schon warum
das nicht gleich so ging also ich habe
durchaus verstanden dass die cdu sagt
sie hat ein problem damit einen linken
ministerpräsidenten zu wählen weil da
gibt es einfach große differenzen
aber warum man nicht von vornherein doch
immerhin ein vernünftiges engagement
eingehen konnte dass man sich enthält
dass man sagt okay die
mehrheitsverhältnisse sind jetzt so wie
sie sind und ein minderheitsregierung
war in der konstellation das einzig
mögliche und sinnvolle und einer solchen
regierung gibt man eine chance warum das
nicht gleich möglich war ich verstehe es
nicht
jetzt hat die cdu und die fdp haben
ramelow zwar nicht gewählt aber es gibt
einen sie haben es mal genannt eine
vereinbarung zwischen union und der
regierung ramelow wie man die nächsten
zwölf monate gestalten will
da wird kooperiert unter anderem auch
beim haushalt
ich hab da ja auch schon bei ihnen jetzt
so ein bisschen skepsis raus gehört ist
das ding gut wenn es am ende gar keinen
unterschied mehr macht ob ich cdu werde
oder linkspartei weil am ende kriege ich
dann die regierung ramelow und alle
gegen die afd
man muss schon sehr aufpassen dass nicht
der eindruck entsteht also es gibt jetzt
sozusagen die die große einheits masse
der parteien die sich nicht mehr
unterscheiden und auf der gegenseite
steht die afd
das ist auch völlig falsch also zum
beispiel wenn man sich
wirtschaftspolitischen positionen
ansieht gibt es große übereinstimmung
zwischen der afg und der fdp und der cdu
also da ist soll er die übereinstimmung
dort und zur linken gibt es große
differenzen und ich finde auch wir
natürlich als linke müssen immer wieder
deutlich machen wir haben schon also
völlig andere vorstellungen davon wie
man sozialen zusammenhalt in diesem land
gestalten kann gerechtigkeit auch
weniger ungleichheit als die cdu also
die cdu hat ja wesentliche verantwortung
auch dafür dass es überhaupt eine starke
afd gibt es muss man auch immer wieder
sagen also ohne 15 jahre angela merkel
und ihre politik wäre die afg heute
wahrscheinlich auch in thüringen nicht
so stark wie sie ist und es gäbe gar
nicht gegen die die notwendigkeit
solcher kooperationen aber trotz aller
unterschiede muss man natürlich mit
wahlergebnissen umgehen und man sollte
ja eigentlich auch nicht die man jetzt
wird es in einem jahr neuwahlen geben
einfach durch das ganze desaster muss
dort durch die cdu und die fdp
angerichtet wurde aber an sich ist es ja
nicht sinnvoll zu sagen die leute sollen
immer wieder wählen bis man irgendwann
ergebnis hat das einem gefällt sondern
das wahlergebnis von turin war wie es
war und man hätte auch von vornherein
gucken können wie gehen wir jetzt damit
um stadt eben solche merkwürdigen
harakiri aktionen zu starten wie das
eben leider cdu und fdp gemacht haben
bodo ramelow hatte zugeführt oder dazu
beigetragen dass man plötzlich einen
ganz anderen blick auf die linken hat
also bodo ramelow so ist gefühlt
sozialdemokrat auf jeden fall kein
marxist ist das so wie sich bodo ramelow
gibt ist das der richtige weg für die
linke um in der mitte der gesellschaft
anzukommen also zunächst muss man sagen
marx war auch soziale nicht nur greift
es gab ja damals also das was gegründet
wurde war eine sozialdemokratische
partei
ich finde auch ein ehrliches
sozialdemokraten sehr sympathisch ich
wünschte die spd wäre wieder
sozialdemokratisch also da ist die frage
was versteht man unter
es versteht man darunter und
irgendwelche spinnerten theorien die
keiner durchsetzen kann oder versteht
man unter links das ist mein verständnis
ein ringen um gesellschaftliche
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt darum
dass menschen nicht so gnadenlos
ausgebeutet werden wie das heute zum
beispiel niedriglohnsektor der fall ist
wo menschen teilweise 23 jobs brauchen
und immer noch nicht über die runden
kommen auch der einsatz zum beispiel für
ältere menschen die heutzutage oft in
altersarmut fallen
ich finde das ist für mich links und
deswegen ist ein linker an natürlich
wird's halt interessieren sie sie galten
ja zumindest mal als die galionsfigur
der linken in der linken ob sie auch
sagen okay das ist richtig wir gehen in
die mitte der gesellschaft oder ob sie
im gegenteil angst haben wir verlieren
da unser profil
also wenn ich mir umfragen angucke dann
wünscht sich die mitte der gesellschaft
nämlich die mehrheit der menschen dass
es in diesem gerechter zugeht
also sie finden eigentlich diesen
goldman sachs kapitalismus diese brutale
marktradikalismus wo alles sozusagen
sich rechnen muss mit allen profit
gemacht wird mit krankenhäuser mit
pflegeheim mit wohnungen das findet die
mehrheit nicht gut und deswegen finde
ich hat die linke sogar die dringende
aufgabe um mehrheiten zu werden und ich
bin auch überzeugt wir hätten längst
auch andere andere parlamentarische
mehrheiten wenn die spd teilweise aber
auch meine partei anders aufgestellt
werden also wenn sie die menschen
einfach mehr überzeugen würden statt oft
so belehrend rüber zu kommen auch die
leute oft zu verprellen
indem man sie hauptsächlich so ein
großstädtisches milieu bedient und sich
von den sogenannten kleinen leuten also
einfache menschen die jeden tag arbeiten
die auch kein studium vielleicht gemacht
haben sich von denen doch stark
entfremdet und das finde ich also ich
wünsche mir linke mehrheit natürlich
soziale mehrheiten lange jahre gab es in
deutschland keine linke mehrheit aber
die die jüngsten umfragen das hat sich
gedreht im moment gibt es zumindest laut
einiger institute eine theoretische
theoretisch deswegen weil die wahl ist
ein bisschen hin eine mehrheit für rot
rot grün aber es gibt auch nach wie vor
gewaltige vor
behalte auch bei spd und grünen gegen
eine regierungsbeteiligung der linken im
bund ein vorwurf lautet zum beispiel
also die linke die distanziert sich eben
nicht genügend und eindeutig vom regime
der ddr warum fällt es ihnen denn so
schwer zu sagen diesen einen satz zu
sagen die ddr war ein unrechtsstaat
niemand von uns bestreitet dass es in
der ddr gravierendes unrecht gibt nur
diese ganze debatte ist wirklich auch
von viel heuchelei geprägt ich muss
sagen ich persönlich habe in der ddr
wirklich viel mehr schwierigkeiten
gehabt als die bundeskanzlerin die doch
eine relativ privilegierte position hat
ausland studieren konnte ich durfte gar
nicht studieren
also mir muss man nicht erklären darüber
wie in der ddr repression stattgefunden
hat und wie meinungen unterdrückt wurden
und deswegen finde ich einfach dieses
also jetzt sagen die ein wort oder sagen
sie nicht ein wort sondern die frage ist
nur wie geht man mit dieser geschichte
insgesamt um und da ist zum beispiel die
die cdu also pure heuchelei ich meine
die haben die ost-cdu das war eine
kleine sed haben die komplett übernommen
mit vermögen mit personal in thüringen
weiß man dass mehr leute bei der cdu aus
dieser dieser tradition kommen als
teilweise bei der linken bodo ramelow
ist aus den alten bundesländern
bekanntermaßen und deswegen kann ich das
nicht ernst nehmen gesagt wird deswegen
kann man nicht mit der linken
kooperieren und also dann schiebt man
das mal beiseite diese debatte um diese
eine vokabel unrechtsstaat trotzdem es
taucht ja immer wieder auf ok die linke
distanziert sich nicht genügend von all
dem was es da an statistischer tradition
gibt muss ich jetzt leider anführen an
diesem wochenende strategie kongress der
linken
da steht eine parteikollegin von ihnen
geht ans mikrofon und sagt okay wenn wir
die revolution machen dann werden die
ein prozent reichen in deutschland
werden erschossen
jetzt könnte man sagen ist ja irgendeine
aus der partei ist aber ihr eigener
parteivorsitzender riexinger ist der
versammlungsleiter und er weiß dass
nicht zurück sondern macht auch noch ein
bisschen drüber und setzt eins drauf und
sagt na ja also wir schicken die
zugesetzt gesellschaftlich nützliche
arbeit sprüche schicken sie ins
arbeitslager
also wenn da irgendwo die inter antennen
noch gestimmt hätten dann könnte doch
sowas nicht passiert nein ich finde das
kann alles was da passiert ist also ohne
wenn und aber und ich sage auch also
klar gibt es in vielen parteien hier und
da verrückte und dass jemand auf einer
konferenz auftritt und solchen mist
erzählt ist schlimm genug aber ich
wünsche mir natürlich dass das dann
zumindest sofort und wieder also
wirklich unmissverständlich von vorn und
in dem falle eben vom parteivorsitzenden
zurückgewiesen wird das hat nicht
stattgefunden und ich finde das wirklich
unerträglich was da war aber nun muss
man sehen inzwischen hat sich eric
singer entschuldigt es hat sich die
betreffende genossen entschuldigt es ist
trotzdem ein vorgang gewesen der mich
entsetzt hat also ich muss sagen ich
habe das vorher schon gesehen weil ich
habe diese konferenz teilweise im
livestream verfolgt und ich bin ziemlich
blass geworden weil dieser szene und ja
also mehr da jetzt darauf bezug nimmt
da muss man sagen das war jetzt wirklich
eine fehlleistung sondergleichen
der türkische präsident erdogan erpresst
deutschland erpresst die eu in dem er
den geschlechtern sagt hier die grenze
ist offen
befürchten sie eine wiederkehr der
flüchtlingskrise schon 2015
naja man muss ja sagen das ist ja ein
absolut zynisches spiel was erdogan dort
spielt und ich finde dass das teilweise
auch in der berichterstattung nicht
wirklich deutlich wird also man muss ja
sagen das ist jetzt auch noch mal so
viele flüchtlinge gibt auch in idlib
das liegt ja nicht nur an den syrischen
machthaber assad und es liegt auch nicht
nur in den russen es liegt vor allem
auch daran dass erdogan selber in der
region natürlich wieder zündet dass er
die ganze zeit daran gearbeitet hat
diese terroristen und idlib ist die
hochburg der des terrorismus also da
gibt es über 40.000 wirklich massiv
bewaffnete islamistische terroristen von
al-qaida vom islamischen staat und
erdogan hat die die ganze zeit gestützt
hat sie finanziert hat sie bewaffnet und
setzt sich jetzt an ihrer seite
auf diesem krieg ein und führe dort
krieg für sie und natürlich ist es gut
dass die eu sie dabei nicht unterstützt
aber dass er jetzt quasi die
leidtragenden die
des ganzen konflikt auch noch
instrumentalisiert und an die grenze
lockt ist wirklich unerträglich und ich
finde natürlich ist es völlig richtig
die eu darf sich nicht erpressen lassen
alleine schon diese dieser ganze deal
dieses dealen mit erdogan ist
problematisch weil er ist ein hauptgrund
dafür dass dieser krieg immer weitergeht
und deswegen finde ich die konsequenz
muss jetzt wirklich sein dass man alles
dafür tut den krieg zu beenden in syrien
das ist möglich der größe der größte
teil des territoriums ist ja schon von
diesen islamisten weitgehend befreit und
man muss jetzt sehen ermöglichen einen
wiederaufbau zu starten und das was am
meisten daran hindert sind diese
schrecklichen sanktionen das ist ja ein
ganz brutales sanktions regime was
wirklich medikamente nahrungsmittel
finanztransaktionen ersatzteile alles
limitiert oder nicht limitiert sondern
verhindert also nichts kommt nach syrien
die menschen können überhaupt nicht zu
einer normalität zurückkehren und
deswegen gibt es auch so viele
flüchtlinge im ausland weil sie in ihrer
heimat nach wie vor nicht die geringste
perspektive haben aber was natürlich
keine lösung wäre es jetzt zu sagen wir
bestätigen erdogans propaganda und
machen die grenzen auf weil das einfach
nicht zu bewältigen ist das eine ist das
was in syrien passiert das andere ist
die frage wie wir mit unseren eigenen
und wie die eu mit den grenzen umgeht
sie haben einen eigenen kanal auf
youtube
da ist jetzt ein heute neu rausgekommen
ein eine ausgabe wochen schonen sie das
glaube ich eben zu den ereignissen an
der grenze und dann sagen das sagen sie
klar und deutlich wir dürfen die grenze
jetzt nicht öffnen
damit sind sie in offenen widerspruch
nicht nur mit dem was die grünen sagen
sondern auch mit dem was zum beispiel
ihre nachfolgerin als
fraktionsvorsitzende bei den linken sagt
amira mohammed ali hat gesagt wir müssen
die grenzen offen was jetzt grenzen
öffnen
die frage ist was versteht man unter
grenzöffnung grenzöffnung bedeutet ja
tatsächlich dass man sagt so zu sagen
wer jetzt hier ist kann kommen und zwar
nicht nur die 20.000 die zurzeit an der
grenze sind das wären bewältigbar das
will ich auch ganz deutlich sagen
natürlich kann die eu 20.000 menschen
aufnehmen ohne dass das hier zu
erschütterungen führen
sondern es wäre ja so wenn man die
grenzen öffnet hieße das ja jeder der
auch dann noch auf sich sie auf den weg
macht könnte durch und wir müssen
einfach sehen es sind fast vier
millionen flüchtlinge aus syrien in der
türkei
und wenn einer behauptet dass europa ist
bewältigen könnte diese vier millionen
menschen aufzunehmen
das ist wohlfeil und ich meine auch die
grünen ich muss man wirklich ehrlich
sagen ich finde dass irgendwo unehrlich
wenn die grünen in der regierung saßen
würden sie jetzt nicht fordern die
grenze zu öffnen weil sie genau wüssten
wie die konsequenzen aussehen da sie
nicht in der regierung sind kann man das
wohl fall fordern da fühlt man sich ganz
menschlich dabei und ganz humanitär und
man muss ja nicht für irgendwelche
konsequenzen gerade stehen
es geht ja gar nicht nur darum was
wirtschaftlich geht sondern es geht
darum was was unsere demokratie
verkraftet und wenn ich mir umfragen
angucke will die mehrheit das nicht und
wenn ich mir nicht wünsche dass sie auf
den noch stärker wird dann kann man
nicht dinge tun die genau das im effekt
bewirken und diese völlige kontrolle
losigkeit die 2015 gab also es geht
nicht darum ob man einzelne aufnimmt
sondern das eine situation entsteht wo
die menschen das gefühl haben ist es
nichts mehr unter kontrolle
wenn man das heute noch mal zu lassen
würde und dass in der situation wo die
wirtschaft möglicherweise
rezessionsgefahren hat wo wir viele
andere ängste und unsicherheiten haben
wer so etwas zulässt der ist nicht
verantwortungsvoll das muss ich einfach
sagen und es ist auch unehrlich weil es
keine lösung für drei millionen menschen
gibt sie in die eu zu holen das sind
menschen die aus syrien geflohen sind
also muss man sich darum kümmern dass es
in syrien wieder eine heimat für sie
gibt das ist zurzeit nicht so aber die
eu könnte sehr viel dazu beitragen dass
das in zukunft wieder entsteht mit
dieser haltung die sich da jetzt gerade
geschildert haben da haben sie sich in
den letzten fünf jahren sehr viel ärger
eingehandelt in ihrer eigenen partei
teilweise sind sie auch aus anderen
parteien kritisiert worden man hat ihnen
vorgeworfen sie würden da die
argumentation der kfd übernehmen aber
sie bleiben dabei das ist richtig und
wichtig und man muss es so betonen wie
sie sagen
unsere aufnahme kapazität ist begrenzt
ja es geht ja nicht um komplett
abschottung ich finde zum beispiel auch
richtig dass man unbegleitete kinder aus
allen lagern rausholen weil das ist
einfach nicht zu vertreten weil sowas
menschen durchmachen
aber wir haben es doch damals erlebt wir
haben eine politik eine politik
verfolgten das ist die verantwortung von
frau merkel die ja auch mit den folgen
der flüchtlingsaufnahme bis heute nicht
wirklich zu rande gekommen ist die
flüchtlinge sind überwiegend da gibt es
studien in die wohnviertel gegangen wo
die ärmeren boden das heißt die kommunen
die sowieso schon überfordert waren wo
soziale brennpunkte sind wo die schulen
überfordert sind wo die infrastruktur
nicht da ist da sind die probleme
verschärft worden
und wenn dann menschen die vielleicht in
den wohl den guten wohnvierteln wohnen
wo es die ganzen probleme nicht gibt die
sich übrigens oft auch die gleichen sehr
darum kümmern dass ihre kinder auf
schulen gehen wo die migrations quote
sehr gering ist wenn die dann immer ihre
humanität entdecken indem sie dann
öffentlich fordern ja wir müssen die
grenzen öffnen alle müssen her kommen
und selber haben sie überhaupt nichts
mit den ergebnissen zu tun weil sie
einfach in einem geschützten raum leben
dann muss ich sagen das ist eine debatte
die ich nicht nachvollziehen kann und
die die es auch bei gott und deswegen
finde ich wir brauchen eine realistische
politik wir brauchen auch eine
realistische hilfe und die hilfe sollte
vor allem da stattfinden wo die meisten
flüchtlingen sind und wo die ärmsten
sind und das betrifft ja genauso auch
afrika also die die menschen die dort
hungern auch die klimaflüchtlinge
die meisten haben nie eine chance nach
europa zu kommen sind viel zu arm die
können kein schlepper bezahlen die leben
vor ort im elend da könnte europa viel
machen auch durch andere handelspolitik
dadurch dass man den ländern ermöglicht
dass sie auch ihre wirtschaft mehr
schützen dass sie ihre eigene subsistenz
produktion schützen
das macht man alles kaputt und dann und
auch die grünen haben da nie
widersprochen aber dann inszeniert man
sich als große humanität verfechter also
das ist das nervt mich und das ärgert
mich auch so war die aktuelle politik
aber haben wir gesagt wir wollen auch
noch ein bisschen was über sie
persönlich erfahren wir haben ein paar
fotos vorbereitet die hamburg aus dieser
biografie über sie nettes foto vorne
drauf
ja wir können sich fotos anschauen wir
beginnen die 80er jahre teenager-alter
erstaunlichen wandlungen mal brav dann
als punk hatten sie mit glückliche
jugend also im großen und ganzen ja ich
bin ja das mit ihrer mutter kaum zu
unterscheiden
also sie sind diejenige legen also ich
bin ja zunächst mal lange bei meinen
großeltern aufgewachsen und habe da
wirklich eine sehr gut behütete kindheit
gehabt ich hatte ein bisschen das
problem ist halt anders aus und ende der
ddr gab es nicht viele die so und
unglauben und klare hatten ich wurde
hannah mutter und er würde war schon so
dass ich da auch ein bisschen gemobbt
und geärgert wurde bei anderen kindern
aber ansonsten hatte ich eine schöne
kindheit also ohne wenn und aber
ja und dann die sahra wagenknecht so wie
wir sie seit seit 30 jahren kennen
die haare immer nach oben geflochten
immer ein sehr elegantes kostüm ist
eigentlich ein würde ich mal sagen
ungewöhnlicher kleidungsstücke für eine
linke oder ich weiß nicht wie sie darauf
kommen dass linke irgendwie in sack und
asche gehen oder mit schlampigen
pullovern rumlaufen müssen also links
heißt doch dass ich mich für eine
bessere gesellschaft einsetzen also ich
wünsche mir natürlich auch dass
eigentlich jeder sich gute kleidung
leisten kann dass man nicht in diesem
billigjobs muss und weil man einfach gar
nichts besseres oder sogar noch sechs
also das ist doch mein anlegen und ich
finde also jeder sollte sich so klein
wie er sich wohl fühlt und soll man der
öffentlichkeit finde ich das kostüm
schon angemessen privat würde ich mich
eher anders kleiden wir haben auch noch
ein paar private fotos begegnet man hier
backen und kochen ist das ein faible von
ihnen haben wir dafür warb zeit also ich
gebe zu backen habe ich tatsächlich als
jugendliche gelernt von meiner großtante
die das sehr gut konnte also diese
thüringer back weise die ist nämlich
wirklich ja also ich bin ja in thüringen
aufgewachsen und thüringer kuchen
hefekuchen mit ganz schmalen teig
erstmalig den sehr gern und den habe ich
auch wirklich gut gekonnt backen kochen
konnte ich lange gar nicht
eigentlich habe ich das erst jetzt bei
meinem jetzigen man ein bisschen gelernt
aber kochen ist nach wie vor nicht meine
spezialität also damit ist das stichwort
ja gefallen sie und oskar lafontaines in
seit vielen jahren jetzt ein paar sei
2014 verheiratet was was verbindet sie
beide also musste ich mir das vorstellen
reden sie immer über politik um gottes
willen nein also das wahrlich nicht also
ich glaube es ist ja ganz selten dass
man das glück hat jemand kennen zu
lernen mit dem einem auf ganz vielen
ebenen etwas verbindet also natürlich
auch politisch dass wir da ähnliche
ansichten haben aber das alleine reicht
ja nicht also da hätte ich ja in vielen
anderen mich verbinden können sondern es
ist eben auch dass wir ähnliche hobbys
haben wir lieben beide das fahrradfahren
mit lieben beide die natur und auch so
von der lebenshaltung einfach haben wir
unheimlich viele gemeinsamkeiten und so
weit ist es wirklich ja bin ich dem
leben dankbar dass ich dass ich das aber
wir haben noch ein foto mit ihnen und
ihrem mann eines der ganz wenigen fotos
wo sie die haare immer offen haben das
ist karneval muss man sagen napoleon und
josef die haare offen das kommt in
öffentlichkeit gehört nicht zu
überstehen
das ist eigentlich mehr pragmatismus
weil das problem ist wenn sie das bild
sehen
das ist mühevoll also das wissen die
meisten männer wahrscheinlich gar nicht
man muss haare vorher also mühsam ein
drehen dann muss man die schönen dann
muss man darf man also nicht etwa an
eine regenwolke kommen oder zumindest
ein regenschauer weil dann ist nämlich
ganzen rock locken weg wenn man selber
keine locken hat ich habe keine und das
heißt es ist eigentlich eher so dass ich
natürlich wenn ich hier in berlin mein
alltag habe auch erst recht wie er
früher war durch getaktet und anfang bis
ende ich habe keine zeit mich tagsüber
um meine haare zu kümmern und ich habe
auch nicht wie frau merkel ein friseur
der mich irgendwie begleitet und sich
darum kümmern kann und deswegen ist die
frisur einfach die praktischere wir
haben vorhin gesprochen über den burnout
sie waren zwei monate völlig krank
geschrieben haben sie völlig aus der
öffentlichkeit zurückgezogen
wie haben sie denn gemerkt es geht nicht
mehr ja das merkt man einfach daran dass
man völlig dummes also ich glaube dörner
ort und burnout ist sicherlich vieles es
gibt menschen die liegendem inhalten
halbes jahr im bett und es gibt aber
auch menschen die haben eine kurze krise
und sagen dass ein burn out also ich hab
es daran gemerkt dass ich einfach ja
völlig kaputt war und und nicht mehr die
innere stärke hatte irgendwo aufzutreten
also ich konnte hatte nicht das gefühl
ich kann jetzt nach berlin fahren und
mache meine normalen termine meine
interviews meine talkshows also alles
was ich immer damals ja und meine
fraktionssitzungen da muss man ja leiten
da muss man ja eine gewisse courage
ausstrahlen sondern das war einfach weg
man ist irgendwie innerlich ja so wie
bei also man ist völlig desolat und das
ist ja etwas was ich auf baut also wie
viele monate schonen dass man irgendwie
immer wieder mal auch deprimiert ist das
gefühl hat ich komme nicht weiter ich
werde zermürbt aber irgendwann
komponiert das so dass es einfach nicht
mehr geht und wie sind sie dann wieder
auf die beine gekommen
also in meinem fall wirklich relativ
schnell also ich hab mir dann diese zwei
monate gehabt und in denen habe ich
darüber nachgedacht wie ich weitermache
ich habe auch in den zwei monaten
relativ schnell mich wieder gefangen ich
habe dann schnell wieder angefangen zu
lesen und es ging mir dann doch auch
vergleichsweise schnell wieder so
relativ gut und dann habe ich eben diese
entscheidung auch für mich getroffen und
als ich das dann entschieden hatte also
dass ich nicht wieder kandidieren als
fraktionsvorsitzender bat diese last und
dieser druck das war damit weg und ab da
ging es mir eigentlich deutlich besser
vielleicht noch einmal kurz zu den
ursachen haben sie das irgendwie für
sich geklärt woran lag es denn dass sie
da dieses mal zusammenbruch hatten
naja da kommen wir immer viele faktoren
zusammen das eine ist natürlich der
normale stress wobei ich denen auch zum
beispiel bundestagswahlkampf hatte also
politik ist immer stress also gewissens
stresslevel hält man aus das kann man ab
uns kann man gar nicht in die politik
gehen aber wenn zu diesem stress den man
an sicher der mit zeit und wenig schlaf
zu tun hat wenn dazu noch sehr viel
negativer stress kommt also interne
konflikte immer wieder angriffe
einmal ein haken also ist es wird immer
wieder gesagt das klima in der
linksfraktion sei besonders schlimm und
ich zitiere jetzt mal einen der jetzt
nicht unbedingt zu ihren
parteipolitischen freunden gehört gregor
gysi hat gesagt bei uns in der fraktion
herrscht hat also ich halte es für
falsch zu sagen das ist eine spezifik
der linken fraktion also wenn ich mir
die geschehene sind der spd in den
letzten jahren ansehe parteivorsitzende
hat nun auch ein gros verschlossen wurde
wenn verschließen wurden wenn ich mir
angucke was in der cdu teilweise ab geht
es ist leider so und ich finde das
wirklich bedauerlich politik hat eine
sehr sehr starke destruktive komponente
das hat vielleicht auch damit zu tun ist
in den parteien vielleicht auch anders
als früher es weniger gemeinsamkeiten
gibt also weniger so eine gemeinsame
strategie bei vielen parteien hat man
das gefühl die haben gar keine
gemeinsamkeit mehr kein profil mehr
keine die wollen eigentlich nicht mehr
irgendwo hin und dann nimmt natürlich
überhand dass man sich gegenseitig
bekämpft ist so politikbetrieb
unmenschlich ach wissen sie das ist
natürlich immer noch jammern auf hohem
niveau also das muss man auch sagen also
was menschen in unserem land teilweise
als reinigungskräfte als postzusteller
oder in solchen berufen oder als
pflegekräfte durch machen jeden tag wo
sie also wirklich extrem stress haben
und dafür auch noch möglich miserabel
bezahlt werden also dagegen muss man
sagen ist politik immer noch ein luxus
betrieb weil man hat zumindest ja keine
existenziellen sozialen sorgen dabei das
ist schon ein großer unterschied
sie haben mal gesagt der wichtigste
faktor dass ich aus dieser krise wieder
rauskam war mein mann
was hatte in oskar lafontaine tun können
um ihnen daraus zu helfen
es war ein es war gar nicht aktives tun
sondern es ist einfach die stabilität
und der rückhalt den man hat wenn man
weiß man hat ein geschütztes privatleben
und dort ist man glücklich also egal was
alles was passiert selbstständig jetzt
irgendwie auch gar nicht mehr bundestag
wäre was ich nicht vorhabe aber trotzdem
habe ich so habe ich da ein refugium ein
bereich der mir ganz viel kraft gibt
weil er mich einfach glücklich macht und
das ist glaube ich schon auch oft so
also bei burnout bei den
schlimmen fällen also die dann wirklich
lang die größer sind als meine kommt ja
oft auch dazu dass dann noch private
probleme sind also dass menschen flächen
entscheidung noch durchmachen und noch
einen beruf stress haben und wenn das
alles zusammenkommt dann hält das ein
mensch oft gar nicht mehr aus wenn aber
das private stabil ist dann kann man mit
dem anderen natürlich ganz anders
umgehen
wie geht es denn jetzt weiter ist es
denkbar dass sie auch wieder an die
spitze mal zurückkommen zb als
spitzenkandidatin bei der bundestagswahl
und da haben sie gesagt mit dem kapitel
habe ich jetzt abgeschlossen und es
kommt was ganz neues
also zunächst mal bin ich sehr froh mit
der rolle die ich jetzt habe ich bleibe
politisch aktive ich mache
veranstaltungen ich werbe für meine
position aber ich habe auch wieder zeit
zu schreiben
ich habe auch wieder ideen für neue
buchprojekte das möchte ich auf jeden
fall umsetzen
klar langfristig man weiß nie was kommt
man weiß ja auch nicht wie sich die
parteien entwickeln also ich wünsche mir
schon dass wir eine starke soziale kraft
in deutschland bekommen und dass das
vielleicht auch mit den
sozialdemokratischen teil der spd und
den teilen der linken die wirklich auch
mehrheiten ansprechen wollen dass da
vielleicht auch etwas neues entsteht und
was man selber in zukunft macht ich
glaube man sollte nie nie sagen
das war für mich persönlich heute mit
sahra wagenknecht herzlichen dank an sie
und herzlichen dann diebe zuschauern
liebe zuschauer an sie zu hause für
interesse machen sie es gut